here's the first story we have in the
new york times justice department issues
40 subpoenas in a week expanding its
january 6 inquiry it also sees the
phones of two top trump advisors a sign
of an escalating investigation two
months before the midterm elections now
this
this is like october surprise territory
they say we're not supposed to do
anything 60 days before an election okay
well they just did and they're go and
they're likely going to keep doing it i
think it's possible trump gets indicted
i don't know for sure
they say the seizure of the phones
coupled with a widening effort to obtain
information from those around mr trump
after the 2020 election represents some
of the most aggressive steps the
department has taken thus far in its
criminal investigation into the actions
that led to the january 6 assault on the
capital by a trope a pro-trump mob
that's interesting they said assault not
insurrection
the extent of the investigation has come
into focus in recent days even though it
has often often been overshadowed by the
government's
legal clash of mr trump and his lawyers
over a separate inquiry blah blah blah
okay now they're just kind of just you
know fluffing words up in this article
we get it the big news is that they went
after trump they went after trump
supporters and trump allies and people
working with trump
so i guess uh
i don't know is banana republic is this
we're gonna have a free and fair
election this november or is the fbi
interfering right now with the
republican party this is a very
dangerous escalation which is being met
with the biden administration laying
down the groundwork for
really not just tough talk but tough
actions we've seen hillary clinton just
today compare trump supporters to al
qaeda we saw kamala harris on 911 at
ground zero describe how threats against
democracy should be treated like
terrorists we saw biden on 911 also
specifically say how terror victims
should stand up for democracy they're
laying the groundwork for something very
serious i think they're acting like a
scared animal that's being backed in a
corner because everyone's telling people
to vote republican whether it's aaron
rodgers whether it's joe rogan they're
coming out and saying hey vote
republican i think they see the
republicans as a threat and i think when
you have an animal that that's in a
corner it could do anything at any
moment and i think the animal's afraid
and it could bite and i think there's
going to be some larger consequences
moving ahead uh as as
you know their grip of power is slowly
unleashing and and you know becoming
loose now you're 100 right and you know
to your question i i think it's the the
latter of the three
uh
and the interesting thing about this is
that all this could have been avoided
um there were speculations of
irregularities in the
you know 2020 uh election and if
the
[Music]
if the appropriate people would have
taken those allegations seriously or
those
those concerns seriously and looked into
it in a
in a responsible way then that would
have
evaded a lot of what ended up happening
i agree so yeah uh they didn't though a
lot of the lawsuits were thrown out on
standing not the merits and my attitude
was
give give them what they want right and
because i i'm like the end result is
likely going to be the same the there's
there was a lot of crazy i mean it's
crazy to me that you had people coming
out talking about venezuelan servers and
gun fights in germany and satellites
stealing data and i'm like okay guys
come on like say oh okay let's hear what
you have to say and let people hear that
because that's going to get dismissed
immediately instead we just got
procedural grounds which i don't know i
got to be honest maybe what they really
wanted was
discontent
you know uh if you take a look at
january 6 there were cops opening the
door for people so maybe they were
thinking like we could quash this but
maybe we want them all riled up so they
act a fool and then we can make them
look bad well they're also invested into
this and i think this is more of a
phishing operation than an actual
investigation because usually when you
have you know the fbi going after
somebody there usually is a crime but
but to go after the the supporters we
don't know exactly who these individuals
are but this is all related to january
6th okay how far away from that date are
we specifically and and and what do they
have they might not have anything but
with these subpoenas they might be
investigating trying to find something
because i think they're desperate for
something to blame the republicans on it
and i'm not a trump supporter and to me
what's happening is extreme extremely
scary and it and it's really bringing us
to a very desperate situation in this
next upcoming election that is dangerous
for everyone well let's say you know
it's a cult because they'll call you
luke a trump supporter yeah even when
you're like i don't like the guy but
this is crazy they'll be like you like
trump i i called him out during his
presidency i thought i think anybody
anyone in power should be held
accountable but but
but again what's happening here to trump
is making everyone in the middle see the
situation and see this doesn't really
add up this doesn't really make sense it
really is an overreach of power and
abuse of power that we see
in a lot of developing countries but
happening here it's it's very very
dangerous especially with our current
cultural climate yeah absolutely certain
a very
uh
negative precedence for the future of
american politics and i would hate to
see people you know on the republican
side doing the same thing for their
democratic uh adversaries and so i i'm
just you know i'm very concerned about
what kind of precedence that's for sure
i think people are losing confidence
especially in the fbi
steve bannon comes out on his show it's
a massive show he's talking with charlie
kirk on another massive show and he says
that they're basically it's a it's a
weaponization it's a political it's it's
biden's gestapo we had that one poll
that showed i think what was it like a
majority of people
thought that uh i think it might have
been rasmussen majority of people
thought that there was a there was an
element of the fbi that were acting like
joe biden's personal gestapo i think it
was james lindsay was it was it james
who said he's on he was on a plane with
somebody that was james yeah some he's
on a plane with some woman and she was
like you know i don't like trump but
the fbi going to his house like that's
too much for me i wonder sometimes
it's hard to know exactly how that's
going to play out is this going to
demonize trump and trump supporters an
attempt for the dem by the democrats to
say haha maga evil
because it seems like that was their
play
they they you know the democrats were
propping up republican candidates
propping up their messages
and the and the media reported as well
they want the trump-supported candidates
the trump endorsements to win so that
they can win in the general so get them
in the primary and this seems to be in
line with that they prop up the
messaging of trump supporters once trump
supporters win 92 endorsement success
from trump they then do things like this
biden comes out and says maga is evil
blah blah blah or extremist and then it
scares the public or maybe it'll have
the inverse effects like how do you how
do you know maybe people will see this
and they'll be like yo they've gone too
far and then end up voting the other
direction
i think historically america has always
bounced out of these situations
whenever we go too far down the left
rabbit hole
i think americans tend to shake
themselves out of it and i think that's
why to your point they're running scared
because
america has such a unique history
uh we are individuals by nature
um
so i think once you once you go too far
once you put americans you know in a
corner they tend to like wake up i mean
trump winning the 2016 election proved
that
uh say what you want about the the the
2020 election but the fact that trump
won the election and the fact that they
put so much effort into demonizing him
and a full-on assault from our media in
in 2016
they they launched this whole insane
theory about trump uh not actually
having one legitimately that the
russians were colluding and a whole
bunch of their nonsense and they were
allowed to do it yeah across the board
across the media the corporate press and
all the institutions were supporting it
they launched fbi investigations well i
think what trump has done for the
country is you know you know like him or
hate him you know he's he's turned the
light on and he's and he's shown us you
know he's forced the hand of our media
in a way that no president in our
lifetime ever has
um and you see a lot of people waking up
and so
again i think you know countries that
have fallen to this ideology in the past
they didn't have our history they didn't
have our spirit
and so yeah and our guns and our guns
yeah i mean to your i mean so i mean you
know
you know in our office space you know
we're kind of divided like there's
there's some people that are more
pessimistic and some people that are
more optimistic i'm more on the
optimistic side because i think
americans
tend to uh pull out of these situations
we saw it in the 60s we saw it in 68
when when they went too far americans
tend to wake up americans tend to go
back to being americans and now we're
seeing it we're seeing it with our
economy uh we're seeing it with you know
people
i think the brilliance of the media is
not only that deception but they they're
good at convincing people
that most people think the way that
they're telling you they think
and so there's a lot more people that
are logical than we know
but because we can only have so many
interactions with people in the
day-to-day so i'm optimistic about
america
and they're gonna push and push and push
because of their desire for power and
eventually it might turn nasty but
americans are generationally free and we
have an independent spirit that no other
country in the history of the world has
ever seen i remember two years ago being
on this show and documenting how biden
and the corporate media got into power
because essentially their their major
campaign slogan was we're not donald
trump he got into office and he kept
saying we're not donald trump donald
trump's bad donald trump met and he kept
obsessing about donald trump and we were
watching his administration were like
okay what are you going to do what
policies are you going to put forward
the democrats don't have anything except
for donald trump as a way to galvanize
the general public and they don't have
anything to show for their records
within the last few years what they have
is devastation they've wrecked this
economy they pushed up world economic
forum great reset policies that have
devastated the middle class that have
made people more poor they have no
record to stand on other than the
destruction of our society and i think
this is why in part we have this
obsession with trump trump trump trump
because they don't have anything else to
stand behind but also at the same time i
do believe that this is a part of a
larger divide and conquer agenda to make
sure blue collar americans fight each
other and this is the perfect kind of
pendulum swing point that we're at where
we have trump and we have biden this is
the perfect way to distract all of us
and have all of us fighting and not
looking at the true cause of our pain
this is this is why they're going after
the maga republicans why joe biden's
like the maggot or we call him maggie
republicans because they know trump's
not going to be around forever they
can't use him as their as their weapon
so when trump you know either retires or
loses or whatever happens they need that
anger because it's the only thing that
brings a left together enough yeah if
trump bows out this is one of the
reasons why i lean a little bit in the
direction of desantis though i'm fairly
split between the two i'm starting to
lean a little bit more desantis these
days it goes back and forth but i think
the reason might be
trump as a powerful prominent figure
is is easily recognizable and easy to
use in media what
either for loving him or hating him
desantis
with all due respect is a more boring
character the people who know him
love him the people who know his
policies respect him but most people
don't care he's not a celebrity donald
trump was the on the apprentice donald
trump is the tv reality guy so everyone
was like oh yeah we know donald trump
and then they get back here's why he's
bad here's why he's good and everybody
just loves to stare at the man i think
if ron has had his wins
they will try the maga republican thing
but it's not going to work yeah so
what's likely going to happen is
right now you have leftists and you have
democrats for some reason united it
makes no sense it's like the the people
who oppose in the one percent teaming up
with the one percent don't ask me why
well i guess you could the answer is
they hate donald trump you get trump
under the equation and they're gonna
scream maga republicans and people are
gonna be like who's that
who are we mad at now i don't know what
you're talking about are we mad at some
maybe that works in local elections it's
not gonna work nationally and then what
happens is the left the democrats this
democratic socialist they they all break
up into different factions once again
fighting each other like occupy wall
street was angry with democrats and then
you're going to get the maga coalition
which is a massive group of
conservatives libertarians post liberals
politically homeless individuals and
then i think you see
some kind of like maga sweep that's if
and when they lose the ability to rally
people around hating trump yeah
like so with this uh last speech that
biden gave like it was pretty pathetic
that here you have a president who's two
years in office and he's making his
latest speech about what trump and
magger republicans
he doesn't have a record to stand on in
terms of the positives that he has been
able to
uh put forth in these past two years and
so he makes it about you know building
an enemy and basically
doubling all focuses on that enemy and
getting people to hate that enemy and
saying things like if we come together
they can we can march forward to a
better future it's it's very pathetic
but you know for me you know to your
point about about desantis uh from a
spectator's point of view desantis have
proven to be
effective in terms of like
uh
staring down and and being effective
against a lot of the kind of woke
policies that are coming uh down the
tubes and so for a lot of people i feel
like they will be attracted to a
desantis type person uh come 2024
based on his effectiveness in a place
like florida and his backbone yeah not
only the effectiveness but also the
prospects of potential peace and not
craziness from the other side that of
course is extremely hyperbolic extremely
sensationalistic and they know if
trump's going to go in there he's going
to be looking for redemption that's the
kind of ideas that's the type of
thinking that a lot of people have and i
would see the the party establishment
galvanize more people against that than
potentially a desantis who again also
interesting figure i go back and forth
on him as well i think any person in
politics should be criticized but you
made that point that i was trying to
make you made it a lot more eloquently
than i did they have nothing to stand on
except for the destruction of the
american working class and i think at
the end of the day both political
parties have caused these policies that
destroyed the blue-collar workers in
this country that have destroyed the way
of life in this country that have
destroyed civil liberties and any kind
of economic prosperity that we had
before and right now i think we're in
limbo of a lot of chaos that that is
hitting people all at once and i think
we're we're even at a point where people
don't know how to even respond to all of
this all at once thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there